We have Mabel Cadena,
who plays Namora.
This is your first red carpet.
How do you feel?
[INAUDIBLE] I feel excited.
I feel nervous.
It's a lot of
emotions right now.
But I'm happy.
Yeah, that's amazing.
You are coming into
the MCU real strong.
[LAUGHING] What was
it like training to be
such a powerhouse character?
Oh.
Well, it was a lot.
We spend one year training.
Physical, mental, and
we are freediving.
We hold our breath under water.
We made an amazing job there.
So it was really hard actually.
Really, really hard.
Well, we actually
hear that you hold
your breath, your first
time that you went down,
it was 8 minutes.
Well, it was 6 and 1/2.
We're going to round that now.
We're going to
give you the eight.
You deserve it.
Oh, [LAUGHING] yes.
No, but Tenoch actually
did an amazing job, too.
Was actually five minutes, I
think, or something like that.
The dedication that
you have to that.
And speaking of the
dedication, we've
seen in the trailer, blue skin.
Now we want to know, there's
some cosplayers out here.
They've painted their skin blue.
Did you have to do
that, or was it CGI?
What was that process like?
Well, I spent six hours for
that process, for being blue.
[LAUGHING] Six hours.
And actually we are
starting eight hours.
And well, the final
time was six hours,
but maybe you can see in
the movie another Namora.
With other skin.
I don't know.
So.
I love the teaser,
the mystery there.
A little tea.
That's good.
Let's see what's happened.
Yes, we're into it.
Now, tell us what it was like
to play a woman from a really
powerful cultural background.
We know that Namora is all
about protecting her people.
Give us a little insight
into that experience.
Ooh, it's a lot.
Because I think thanks for the
legacy, the Chadwick legacy,
to nudge Alex and me, now
we have the opportunity
to represent our cultural,
our Latin culture, so
as a Mexican woman, it's
an amazing experience.
I can play Namora
in this universe,
you know, because we in
Mexico, see a lot of faces.
So I'm very proud that people
like me, like with my face,
with my skin, with
my other culture
can be in this huge platform.
So I'm very excited about it.
Yes.
Yes, the fans are
also equally excited.
They love you so much.
They're excited for the splash.
I'm sorry.
I had to.
The splash you're going to make.
I'm sorry.
Bad jokes here, but thank
you so much for spending
your time out here.
Everybody wants to
go and talk to you,
so we're going to
send you on your way.
Have a great night.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Mabel Cadena.
Say goodbye to the Marvel fans.
Thank you, everyone.